the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so again we go here back up two examples
intro group theory start it up
alright and then our first sample is
group theory one and it just goes
through and basically I sort of came up
with a way in a spreadsheet to define
the functions i was looking at and then
start Creek combinations of them and
then do very simple tests on
associativity and and and and
distributed and all that stuff if you
actually look at the tests I do you
might be like you might Blanche you like
really you said that you you you you
declared that it was fully associative
it's not like I went in did formal
proofs for every this things I just did
some very quick numerical tests the semi
ring test is actually takes a while here
as you can as you can see and this will
take a minute here and it even appears
to be hanging oh no it's not good okay
we'll let it go through that so facts
while it does that we can look at here
look good so basically these are inputs
so basically I have kind of my different
what I call the sort of the key function
i have Union and intersection and then I
have the sort of the three possible
conditions v1 less than v2 v1 equal to
v2 v1 greater than V 2 and then
essentially the different types of
operators you know the results that can
occur from those and so this is a CSV
file and we read it in as associative
right and so you know looks like a
spreadsheet and I can actually have
columns named v1 less than V to you know
very powerful and in fact I'm even able
to pass that column into the matlab eval
function and have it actually executed
which is nice so I can use you know I
can actually have code in my column or
row names and then have you know
operations performed based on that which
is I think a nice thing that you can do
when you have you know Rose when you
allow the strings to be in your set
likewise matlab will formally parse nan
as nan and plus minus in FFA's minus in
and so I can get all that functionality
out of there which is very nice right
and then it goes through let's see here
right and these are just different tests
that we do on those doing here it's done
not a number i sorta yeah I kind of I
like I use that as kind of like it has a
lot of the properties of null when you
add it to different functions so I kind
of I'm just I'm like yeah I'm using that
for that and it works out pretty well so
it's it's I Triple E failure state modes
or whatever it's how it's supposed to be
it appears like that you know I camera
if there's a plus nan and a negative man
as well no no it's just man yeah yeah
yeah and then actually it goes through
here and I think so here we're doing now
these just uses various little ways of
inputting these are just different
values just different little
spreadsheets that you can make for
exploring these different types of
things and you can just write them as
little CSV files very useful on struct
here I do apologize for the length of
time is taking I think having the
quicktime video recording going at the
same time is is causing the tour
computer to to sweat a little bit more
than a minute those normally usually
doesn't take this long
the outputs that it comes up with so
these are all I basically writes all
these out so look at here this shows I
asked it to basically you know generate
all those 200 pairs so it will do for
different each key and every whatever it
can go and just generate those for me so
I discreet this little thing and it goes
through and just sort of creates this
whole function and then writes that out
as a CSV itself which is very convenient
again these are things you can do I
think this is the one where we came up
with all the films yeah it doesn't
really fit there but you can see these
are the pairs that it found and it shows
this is the 0 operator and again this is
all done with the 4m kinds of values
that it can store you know different
types of things this is how we made all
the tables that are in the arrow pits
writing out results means it's done
there we go and so the main one I just
want to show you is that we read in that
function funk range and we / muted it
and if you do display full a funk you
can see there's the full combination of
values as we saw there so there's really
nothing here for you it's not expect you
to go using D for em to do group theory
things just up there's not really the
point of these examples I did it's more
just showing that you can you know when
you when you go into this larger space
problems that you might not solve linear
algebraically all that sounds like oh
yeah mice you know if I have strings and
other types of things it really opens up
the flexibility I thought that was very
neat that you could do this and it just
handled the data very nicely and without
any any real any real difficulties so so
with that that's the end of this lecture
I know if there's any final questions
before we proceed all right very good
and please if you haven't signed up on
the sheet please please do to please do
so thank you very much
you